six one seven eight three zero 4750
let's go to our next caller from the
four to four area code caller what's
your name and where you're calling from
okay on the road somewhere yeah
caller can you hear me I think this
caller is drag racing Wow
how long can we stick with this I'm
entertained yeah maybe was a butt-dial
this is a very unusual background
I like let's imagine where this person
is I believe that they're at an NHRA
drag yes I think they're on a motorcycle
right oh hey caller are you with us hey
there of course I am of course I'm gonna
call my mother that's on the military in
its current state gonna be able to
continue the call with you because we
there's it sounds like we're on speaker
there's another person talking in the
background song should I think in a car
model yes I would take the intercom oh
hello is that her that's that's really
good what's your question my question is
this yeah
now oh gosh I'm so nervous my question
my name is Kelly card I'm coming from
the Sunshine State of California my
question is why is the bunker Tom get in
the office in the White House the same
day that Paul Manafort was fired yeah
August 11 2016 her and her husband were
in Croatia Wow Putin's ship was docked
in the sea you know good to go me she
went to go meet Rupert Murdoch ex-wife
row Rupert Murdoch
Fox News who tooted the girlfriend well
who with Donald Trump said he did not
want to use any Intel why max
dissing your daughter to go tell windy
to go to a Putin well when he came in
she came in a week before last I was
exhausted of all no one didn't announce
her well she didn't she say that
Ivanka Trump's house and then he went on
to the Governor's Ball my business
that's coated girlfriend yes absolutely
Russia's girlfriend I'm marginally aware
why you're referencing in there when
she's not having had it's a security
clearance I have said with her ex Secret
Service and ours people in service now I
can go visit them I can't go around the
White House because I'm not security
clear the FBI the CIA the CIA Homeland
Security allowing these people dissing
our meetings and then say to me got it
yep point when they really okay yeah I'm
so sorry
able okay thank you so much wow wow shot
out of a cannon Pat I mean I recognize
most of what she was talking about and
listen I'm against Ivanka Trump having
an office at the White House I think
that really is the key thing there was a
lot of fun
that was enjoyed that that's one of the
best calls we've ever had over yeah but
yes I am I am tangentially aware of most
of what was referenced there and I think
my impression is I agree with most of
what was said there let's take a break
more calls after this join us on reddit
david pakman.com slash our EDD IT